Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Whoa, the scary timer above my head.
Hello, everyone.
Um, I had to add to do one more loop because mentally I was just not there yet.
Um, still I'm not.
It's just been, there's been a lot going on.
I didn't really sleep a lot today in general.
Um, and that's why, like, I needed the extra loop just to be, like, just to transport myself back into reality.
Um, hello.
Yes, today is a, uh, today's stream is a birthday countdown.
I do have a very special announcement at midnight, um, when the clock strikes midnight.
Um, um, uh, I do have an announcement today.
I give you guys.
So, we're just gonna, uh, wait until then.
Um, after that, I won't be streaming too long after the announcement.
Um, because we gotta prepare for tomorrow's stream!
Tomorrow's actual birthday stream!
Where there's also another announcement!
Ha ha ha!
Back to back to back to back announcements!
Yippee!
Okay, but these are good announcements, though.
They're, like, really fun, good announcement that feeds you guys.
So, uh, are you hungry, Dragoon?
How hungry are you?
Uh, ha ha ha ha ha!
Lord Kuroo says, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Not even my PC breaking as it did earlier could stop me from wishing you a happy birthday, Doki!
I love this fandom, and I'm thankful every day, uh, to be part of it.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you guys so much for the support.
Uh, Unholy, thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy day of birth, Doki!
Thank you!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it, everybody.
Um, but yeah, I know I said, like, I'd reveal how much the entire thing costs.
I think I'll save that for tomorrow.
I'll save the secret information tomorrow, um, during the birthday stream.
Uh, Solid Snake, thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wishing you the happiest of birthdays, an hour into the future!
Here's some more years to come!
Looking forward to later today!
Thank you again, Solid!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, anyway, guys, uh, if I sound different, um, that, that's my sound team and I are sort of playing around with my mic settings, which is why, like, uh, earlier stream, the Marvel Rivals stream earlier, was a little different as well.
Um, I might have sounded a little quieter than usual, but we did, are playing around with, um, with some sound settings, uh, or some sound settings right now to make myself sound better.
A little!
How so?
How, um, how so, guys?
Uh, what makes, what makes me sound different right now?
Uh, but yes, that's why, uh, it was quieter during the Marvel Rivals stream, because we are trying to fix some stuff.
Uh, and, uh, and we adjusted more after the Rivals stream, we adjusted it more, uh, right, uh, for this stream as well.
So we hope we can find, uh, we hope we can, uh, I sound further away.
Well, to be fair, my, I'm, like, turned away from my mic right now.
So, right here, I'm talking to my mic at the moment right now.
So, I don't know that, um, I don't know if, like, I still sound different, or, oh, I sound softer.
I mean, maybe just because I'm tired.
But we're trying to make, we're trying to make it so that I sound the, right, um, I sound, like, louder than the last stream.
So, uh, my sound team, if you are monitoring this stream right now, um, and want me to adjust anything live, I can, um, just because, like, you know, we have a fucking hour to kill.
Ophelion, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
Another year where I'm proud to be a dragoon.
And, uh, you're my kamioshi.
Hope to get a ton of rest after all these announcements.
Thank you, thank you again for the Akasupa.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Also, my food's gonna be arriving in the middle of the stream because I actually didn't eat dinner, um, right after the concert.
You know, I had to do a little bit of work and then I went straight to doing the Marvel Rival stream.
Like, and I took a nap and then did the Marvel Rival stream.
And I had to do a little bit of work and then I took a nap again and now I'm here.
So, I ordered some food.
I ordered some Japanese skewers.
Uh, so it's gonna arrive.
It might be arriving in the middle of the stream.
So, uh, you're gonna hear my, uh, ringtone.
So, yeah, I don't know what the ringtone is because I know that... I don't know if it's a custom ringtone, so... I hope I don't get copyright strike.
I would be very sad because of... Okay, so it's two things.
It's... Okay, so the ringtone could be one of two things.
It could be Teenage Dream from Glee or...
Or Spooky Scary Skeleton, the remix.
So, it's one or the other.
And I know I can get copyright strike on either of those songs.
So... One or the other is gonna get me.
But I need to make sure the ringtone's on.
Because I'm worried I'm gonna miss it.
Because the Glee version is the superior version.
It's from the... Excuse me.
It is from the Dalton Glee Club.
Um, where they sing it all in acapella.
And it's really, really good.
It's so much better than the original Katy Perry version.
Like, I don't... I cannot listen to the original Katy Perry version after listening to the...
The acapella Dalton Academy Glee Club.
Uh...
Teenage Dream.
Um...
Anyway.
Uh...
Let's see.
Seijian, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
Thank you so much for the amazing company.
You bring us in your live stream.
Thank you again for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, Mike.
Please, uh...
Komplenos, Doki.
I don't know if I... I'm pretty sure I didn't pronounce that correctly.
I'm pretty sure I butchered that.
Uh, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I was gonna be at the beach, but I thought it'd be weird because, like, I only have daytime beach time.
So...
I thought... I figured it'd be pretty weird for me to be there.
So that's why I was like, you know, okay.
You know, it's... it's 11 p.m.
I might as well, like...
I should... I should be in there, like...
I should be more immersive.
Uh, but thank you.
Welcome to the Tomato Farm host.
Welcome, welcome.
Um...
Yeah, I don't have a nighttime beach out...
Beach background for us.
Um...
But yes, uh, I'm... I'm...
I'm just so happy it's done.
Um...
But for those who...
Uh, didn't know...
I know I keep saying this a lot.
But for those who, like, heard me say this, like, a millionth time.
But I had, like...
In only a month to get all of this done.
And, like...
That's crazy.
The fact that I did all of the concert within just a month.
Learning, like, you know, the choreo.
And, like, doing, like, uh...
The motion capture.
And, um...
Grabbing people to be able to...
Grab people to be, like, guests at my concert.
Like, within a month, by the way.
Like, literally, we could only...
We had to have all the record...
Uh...
All the...
All the, like, the, you know, mixing and stuff.
Done, um...
Uh...
By...
From everybody.
To get all the mix...
Like, all the recordings for the songs.
For the mixing.
It had to be done within, like...
A week and a half.
And then, um...
And, like, you know...
We had to plan, like, choreo and everything.
And...
Oh my gosh.
It was actually crazy that I did all of that within just a month.
Um...
To be fair...
And I need you guys to know...
I wasn't sponsored...
Or anything.
Like, no company sponsored this concert.
No, like, outside group sponsored it at all.
All the money...
All the funding for this concert was from my own money.
Um...
So I paid for everything.
For everybody.
So, like, you know, like, the mixing for, um...
All my guests.
And, like, um...
The...
Like, the motion capture for everyone.
Like, it all came...
The expenses all came from me.
So, uh...
I basically sponsored, uh...
My own stuff.
Like, my own concert.
Um...
And to be able to do that...
It was because of you guys.
You guys provided me the opportunity.
Um...
By you guys supporting me.
It allowed me to do something, um...
Like this for you guys.
So, um...
And this...
I know some of you guys are wondering, uh...
When, uh...
Uh...
When will this, uh...
Concert be uploaded onto YouTube?
So, because it was done within a month.
There are, like, little small mistakes here and there.
Like, it's not...
Obviously, like, it can't be perfect.
Because, like...
There were, like, some small mistakes here and there.
Um...
For, uh...
Like...
For some stuff that we were gonna fix.
And, um...
And so...
Because of that, uh...
We're gonna have to...
We're gonna have to fix that throughout the...
We're gonna have to fix it and, like...
Uh...
Make it more polished and everything.
For the actual, like...
Upload onto the channel.
And because, you know...
It's gonna be a bit...
Um...
Because the...
3D production team...
Um...
They told me that they do have another project...
Right after mine.
So they have to...
Change...
Like, they have to focus on that first...
Before they can go back and, like...
Polish everything up.
So...
It might...
I don't know...
I'm waiting for them to give me...
An exact time frame at the moment.
Uh...
At the moment for it.
So, um...
Uh...
They have yet to give me a time frame...
Um...
On...
When that will be...
Uh...
Done.
But I will try my best to give...
You know...
Be transparent about all of this and everything.
Um...
And so...
But it is crazy.
The quality that I received...
For the entire production...
And the concert itself...
Uh...
For it being a month...
Is actually...
Like...
Uh...
When you see...
Like...
You know...
You guys see the recordings of it...
From people who were there.
But...
Um...
The actual...
Like...
Production for it...
With the HD version...
It's crazy that that was done within a month.
Like...
Also, you might notice...
Also...
I'll let you guys know right now...
The escape...
So...
Uh...
This...
We...
Sloppy Sisters showed up for...
A special appearance...
At the...
Uh...
At the birthday concert...
And...
Um...
The song we did was...
Escape from the City...
Uh...
So...
You guys might notice that...
Compared to the other...
Like...
The other...
Songs in the set list...
Like...
We were just standing there...
Um...
Well...
It's because we sort of did the...
Motion capture for...
That particular...
We did the motion capture for that particular song...
Like...
Individually...
So we couldn't really...
Interact with each other...
Ha ha ha ha...
Cause like...
You know...
We couldn't really like...
Interact with each other...
Uh...
So like...
You know...
Mint did her motion capture for it...
Like...
In Japan...
And everything...
And...
Yeah...
So...
Um...
So you see that like...
Uh...
We're like...
Standing there...
And we're just like...
Moving at our spot...
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha...
So...
Ha ha ha...
Ha ha...
So, but in the polished version, we're planning on redoing the motion capture.
My immersion!
I'm just trying to explain why we were all just standing there.
Because we're like, oh, man.
Because, like, I felt really bad.
Because I was like, oh, this is, like, the lack of... I felt like there might be, like, the energy for it is different from...
The other... but it was still pretty hype.
Because, like, you know, everyone did amazing in it.
This was Snuffy and...
Laimoo's first time...
First time doing, like, something like this.
Like, a concert.
And this was, like, you know, it's actually pretty funny.
Because this was actually Laimoo's first...
Like, she had the 3D model for, like, a year now.
And she couldn't... didn't know what to do with it.
So this was, like, the first time she could actually, like, use it.
Like...
And then Snuffy's 3D model was actually done within, like, a week.
Like, I think it was a week.
Because I, like, when I invited them to my concert, I asked them, like, oh, do you guys all have...
Do you guys all have 3D models?
Like, for Laimoo and Snuffy.
Because I know Mint does.
And, uh, Snuffy was like, oh yeah, I'm having a new debut for my new, um...
For my new design.
And, um...
Uh, she was, like, asking me, like, is that okay?
If we could get, like, if I could use my newer 3D, like, newer design.
And I was like, yeah, but, like, I do need to know, like, when can you get the 3D model done?
So we could, like, you know, have it be ready for, uh, for, like, uh, everything.
For, like, production and stuff.
And her modeler actually got it done within a week.
Which was absolutely insane how fast that was.
Um, for, like, the quality that, like, we received.
It was really, really good.
Um, and so, uh, yeah, so, like, uh, yeah, it was, I, it was, like, I knew it was less than 4, a week.
But, like, had, someone said, Snuffy said it was 4 days.
So, yeah, it took 4 days for, for her to finish that model and everything.
So this was, like, their first time doing this.
And, um, and, um, obviously, like, I'm glad to give them that experience as well.
Like, they didn't have to pay for anything of it.
And, like, I basically, we, I would say, we basically paid for it.
Hahaha!
Because my money is your money.
Uh, hahaha!
George, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my gosh, I'm sorry, I'm really bad at reading Chinese.
I can see Lei, and then, blank, blank, blank, blank, blank, blank, blank.
And the ending word is San, haha, which is mountain.
I, I, I think that's San.
I think that's mountain, right?
Uh, you're the proud of many Chinese in Canada.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I, I think if I could have someone else read it out for me, I know what that says.
I, hahaha!
I, I, no, it's okay!
You're right!
I'm just, I'm, I'm, my reading level is at a, uh, is at, like, a third grade level.
I think it's worse now, because I haven't read Chinese in a long time.
I can listen to Chinese, uh, hahaha!
And speak it, obviously.
But thank you again for the super chat!
That really means a lot!
Thank you!
Um, for, thank you to the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you to my Kamiyoshi!
Happy birthday!
I've been a long time lurker since from the before times, but about a year ago, I decided to start interacting in chat, because I wanted to show you my love and support!
I'm so proud of you, and I'm happy to be a dragoon!
Cheers!
Doki!
Thank you again for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm glad, I'm glad you've been enjoying your, uh, time.
It really, really does, uh, mean a lot to me.
Um...
Uh...
Oh, sorry if I lost.
I can read that.
She mean Kuala!
Hahaha!
I can read that!
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Wait, what was...
Hahaha!
I forgot what my topic was!
Oh, it was about the, uh...
Meep!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Meepa!
Welcome, meep!
Thank you again for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, wait.
What was I talking?
Okay, I was talking about the...
Oh, the model and stuff.
Um...
And...
So, it was like, you know, every...
Everything just came together at like the...
Hahaha!
At like, uh...
The...
Last possible moment.
Everything came together.
Also, my...
Third monitor...
Died.
I...
Well, it didn't die!
Okay, this is like an issue.
Like...
I need to like...
Fix this real quick.
Sorry.
It like...
Stopped...
Showing up.
Wait, did it actually?
Why is it not turning on?
Hahaha!
That's not good.
Okay, okay.
Turn on.
Okay, I was like...
I was like...
Why is it not turning on?
Oh...
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
Okay, there you go.
Everything's okay.
Hahaha!
Okay, let me check my...
Food too.
Real quick!
Alright.
Sorry.
I'm all over the place.
I'm so hungry.
I'm...
Santino!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy Dookie day!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, what was I on?
Oh, yes.
Um, because of the fact that, like, it's gonna, uh, it might take a bit for it to, um, for it to be, like, uh, uploaded, I am planning on adding maybe, like, two more songs, uh, two bonus songs to the concert, um, only because, like, uh, you know, it's just,
like, a little, special thing, because it, and also because the concert's only, like, 33 minutes, so.
So, I need to pad the time a little bit, because I didn't even realize, I was, like, oh my god, like, I did seven songs with three MC portions, and that's only 33 minutes?
I was, like, oh my god, okay, we need to pad the time a little bit.
So, um, I'll add, like, two more in there.
Like, we'll do, we'll do some more, we'll add some, well, I'm planning on adding two more songs into the, um, into the actual, uh, oh my gosh, my third monitor is, like, not okay.
It, like, like, it keeps, it keeps turning off!
I can't see my super chat!
Give me a sec, I'm going through stuff right now.
It keeps, like, I don't know why it does that.
That's so annoying.
Also, I hope the BGM is working.
Um, yeah, that ain't good.
My third monitor keeps turning off.
Why today?
It's my birthday week!
I should, I should have a good day!
I...
Today should be a good day for me!
Um, um, um, uh, cooperative.
Thank you for the Akasupa, thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki!
You're truly the, the gigabird!
Cheers!
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Um, anyway, uh, what?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, wait.
Maybe it's this.
I think I know what to do.
It's like a pop-up that pops up.
Okay.
Alright.
That's my birthday.
Typically enough.
Hello?
What did I execute?
Oh my god, what did I do?
It says, execute... Oh my god, did I actually execute it?
Okay, wait.
We gotta fix this again.
Oh my god, PLEASE!
I need my third monitor!
Actually, I can't read Super Chats without it!
Oh!
I think it's because, like, I have, like, three really tanky monitors that, like, my PC is not okay.
My PC is not okay.
I killed it!
Um, uh...
Um...
We're, oh yeah.
Okay, so, as I was saying, uh, because...
Because, um, like I said, uh...
We are polishing up the concert more.
Um...
For, like, the...
Like, my director's cut.
Um...
I am planning on...
I...
What is this?
The panel protect process did not complete.
Please press the execute button.
Dude, what the fuck?
What?
During process, please do not unplug the power cord from the monitor.
No!
What?
Okay.
Okay, whatever.
Uh...
I'm, like, reading.
There's, like, this, like, little notification on my third monitor.
But it's, like...
I'm, like, reading.
I'm, like, what is this?
Okay, I don't think I'm gonna have access to my third monitor today.
I...
I have no idea what the fuck is going on.
Anyway!
This third monitor is, like, interrupting everything that I'm trying to say.
As I was trying to say...
Uh...
Um...
Wait, oh my god.
Yes, the third...
The third monitor died again.
Like, I don't know.
Maybe it's updating the firmware and that's why we don't see anything.
Uh...
So...
Alright.
That's fine.
I guess I don't have a third monitor at the moment.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
I don't have chat then.
Let me...
Okay, I need...
Let me grab...
Okay, I need to grab chat real fast.
So at least I can re-chat.
Oh my god.
It keeps interrupting me.
Um...
Mal, welcome to Tomato Fire.
Welcome, welcome.
Okay.
For real now.
So...
Because...
You know, we're gonna be polishing up.
I am planning on redoing the choreo for...
Uh...
For escape from the city.
So we're actually like interacting and moving around the stage instead of us just standing there.
Because, like, it's still pretty good.
I'm still...
I'm happy about...
Uh...
Everybody...
Um...
Really enjoying that...
Really enjoying it as well.
And I've obviously like...
I know it's already like really good.
But I wanna elevate it even more.
To like, you know, make it so that, you know, we're actually interacting with everyone.
Um...
I wanna make use of the...
The stage a lot more too.
So...
Um...
Uh...
So that's what like...
What I wanna do for it.
For the more polished version.
So...
What you see...
The recordings you see...
And what you saw there...
Was...
Is...
Obviously that's a con...
Like the...
The concert version at...
Um...
At Anime Expo.
But I am planning on like...
I love...
Like that's the only one that I'm planning on like redoing.
In terms of the choreo itself.
But I know like everybody...
I was so happy that everybody enjoyed it.
And we're singing along to it.
And...
Uh...
We're having a great time too.
More...
More falls!
Thank you to the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Can you bring anything for your birthday?
Can you give me the Supa?
Of course!
Thank you again for the support!
I really appreciate it!
You've been supporting me for so long!
More falls!
I still...
I do appreciate it!
Thank you again for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Ryden!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Saiya5lov!
I wish you the best!
And you should play some...
Curse Halo after you finish the game!
Or the faux saga!
Hope you can co-op with fans!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Mal!
Thank you for five gifted ships!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
But yeah, okay, for those who don't know, Hiro, like, people were like, oh yeah, oh my gosh, Hiro, like, out of nowhere.
But she was the one that actually introduced me to the 3D studio.
Because it's actually, for those who don't know, the 3D studio that worked on this was from, let me see, what are their names?
Uh, was, uh, from Hiro, was from Hiro Esports.
And if you guys don't know what Hiro Esports, who Hiro Esports are, they're actually one of the biggest, um, Esports orgs in China that helped me, um, produce this.
So, uh, they've done, they produced a lot of, like, amazing concerts.
And, uh, oh, it's H-E-R-O, like, Hiro as in, like, superhero.
Uh, so, no, no, not Hiro, not the, not her name, but it's actually Hiro, superhero, Hiro, Hiro Esports.
But they're, like, the, if you Google them, they're, like, the biggest Esports, uh, org that organizes, like, all the biggest, like, um, Esports events in China.
Let me, let me, I don't remember, uh, I forgot it on the top of my head, to be fair.
Um, but they basically, um, they did the, they helped develop the, okay, what was it?
I was reading it, I was like, holy shit.
I was like, oh my, they basically helped, they ran the, oh my god, did they actually?
Okay, they helped produce the, the Olympic Esports Week, and, oh, what the fuck?
Okay, okay, okay, I forgot about that.
They basically did, like, the Olympic Esports Week for Asia, and then they've done, like, the League of Legends.
Yeah, they've done League of Legends, they helped organize the League of Legends tournaments that are hosted in China as well.
Um, as well as PUBG.
So, they did majority of, like, basically majority of the, uh, tournaments that you see in China when it comes to, like, Esports stuff.
So, they were the ones that helped me produce the, um, produce the entire concert.
So, it was really, so, like, a huge thank you to, uh, to Hiro for setting me up with the, uh, 3D production team.
Because, like, I was having a hard, especially, like, with the deadline, too.
Because I was, like, asking several, like, JP studios as well.
And a lot of them couldn't really, uh, I got, like, rejected, like, declined.
I won't say rejected, but, like, they saw the time frame, like, you know, within a month.
And a lot of them were, like, we can't do that.
Like, for the JP studios, they were, like, a lot of sudden they couldn't do it.
And then, like, and then they're, like, we have to find people.
We're gonna have to, like, check other people's schedules and everything.
And then, like, obviously time was running out.
So I went with... I asked Hiro if I could use her... her... her orgs, her companies... because she's under Hiro Esports.
So I asked her if I could use her 3D production team because she did her 3D debut with them and everything.
And it looked really good.
And I've seen some examples of what they've done in the past.
I was like, you know what?
Okay, can they do it?
Like, at first I was like, can they do it?
And they were like, yes, we can do it.
And I was like, oh my God, thank God.
I was like, oh, thank fucking God.
They could do it within a month as well.
I was so, so happy.
Because like, if this is what they could do within a month, just think about what they could do if they actually had like more time.
Actually, add more time to put everything together.
Like, it could have been a lot better if it wasn't like within a month.
Also, okay, I'll show you guys a funny, I'll show you guys a funny production photo.
When we got all our models like in, added in.
Just to like, and they're like, oh, so like the production team were like, so like, what are your heights?
Because, uh...
What, what are, oh, wait.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, give me a sec.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, it's not a copyright ringtone.
Thank God.
Unless, unless Apple decides to copyright me.
It, it should be fine.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, it wasn't, it wasn't teenage dream or, um, or spooky scary skeletons.
Oh, we're okay.
Um, okay.
So, um, they like asked me like, so what are your heights?
Because, um, when you sent us the models, everybody's heights are very different.
And I was like, what do you...
I was like, oh, what do you mean by that?
And okay, I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys.
This is them like inputting, like, you know, inputting the model in.
And then I was like, what the fuck, Snuffy?
So, so she was a lot, she was gonna be a lot shorter.
I was like, yeah, that's not right.
That's not that.
I was like, wait a minute.
This, this does not make sense.
So, um, so, we, uh, we had to like, be like, oh, yeah, like, no, she's not, she's not that small.
I thought that was, um, um, really funny.
Also, like, honestly, my favorite, one of my favorites is the right drag wound.
So, I did party rock anthem.
Um, I learned how to shuffle.
I actually, there is another choreo that was done for that specific part.
That, um, we tried out.
But, um, cause like, it was like, cause like, um, we're like, do we do the shuffling?
Or like, do we do like, but obviously the shuffling is so iconic that we kept the shuffling instead.
And, um, and, but there is a different version of, of the choreo.
That'll show tomorrow.
Every day we sh, every day we're shuffling.
moot, moot, moot, moot.inding, moot, moot, moot, moot, moot, moot, moot, moot, moot!
Okay, so, um, um, um, for those who are, okay, I- I thought it was really funny because, like, it's basically like... You know, like, Katy Perry, left shark and right shark?Hahahahha!
That was, that was my inspiration.
So, for those who didn't see the recordings yet.
There is a specific moment there where... where a dragoon pops out and it's a giant fucking ass dragoon mascot that's like dancing with me.
So it was like, you know, it's like basically left shark, but like left right dragoon.
And people were wondering, okay, I don't know if you guys noticed the voice, who it was in terms of...
of like the voice.
Basically, I asked... I asked Shachi if she wanted to do this because I was like, I need someone to be the female voice in this concert because I was like, oh yeah, I need someone to sing this fucking part because it's so hard.
And I wasn't going to be like Doki Bird with Doki Bird and Doki Bird because I was already... it was already Doki Bird and Doki Bird and like I needed one more because I can't sing that high.
And I needed someone to be the female voice.
So I like asked her, I was like, bro, you down?
Like, do you want to sing Party Rock Anthem with me?
And like, do you want to do a Party Rock Anthem?
And like, you know, it's also a short part too.
It's not like too long.
She just shows up at the end and be like, what was it?
Put your hands up.
Like, it's such a short part.
She just repeats it over and over again.
And she was like, bro, I'm fucking down.
She was like, she was like, I can't believe you're singing Party Rock Anthem at a concert.
And I was like, indie baby.
She was just like, I can't believe you're doing...
She was like, bro, I'm so fucking down.
Um, and, uh...
Um, but yes, that was... that was her.
Um, also, uh, blah, blah, blah, you guys didn't know.
The chorus, originally, there was no backing track to... to me.
When it came to, um, the chorus of, um, of the song.
So, like, it was just me like, everybody...
Oh, yeah, well, fucking...
Oh, my gosh, my brain is so fried that I already forgot how to sing the song.
Oh, my God, that'll be...
Party Rock Anthem.
Guys, my brain is so fried right now.
I already forgot.
Um, Party Rock is in the house tonight.
Everybody just have a good time.
Okay, so you know that part?
It was just gonna be me.
And then we realized that it sounded really awkward.
That it was just gonna be me.
Um, when I was, like, singing it and practicing it.
Um, and so, like, um, we were, like, okay, we should...
Because, like, you know, in the original...
In the original of Party Rock, um, there is, like, a chorus backing to it, too.
So, uh, so...
Within...
I had to get it done within, like, a day to add the chorus backing.
Because, like, you know, we were already so deep into, like, production of everything.
And, like, practicing and all that stuff.
Um, and so, like, I hit up, like...
Obviously, like, Min is in Japan.
So, like, I knew she would be, like, way too busy.
Because I was like, oh, I'll just get all the sloppy sisters to, like, do the chorus.
But, obviously, she's in Japan at the moment.
So, um, so she couldn't...
It was just, like, three lines, too.
Like, we just needed three lines for the chorus.
Um, so, uh, so I asked, uh, you know, I asked Laimu and Snuffy.
And because it's also three different harmony parts, too.
So, each person did a different harmony of Party Rock.
And, uh, so I asked Laimu and Snuffy.
And then also Doobie.
So, all three of them were singing the backing track for Party Rock Anthem.
And they all, like, send me the recordings within, like, the next day.
So, like, a huge shout-out to them for, like, doing that.
Because it was, like, so last minute.
Um...
So, like, I'm really thankful that they were able to do that for me and everything.
Um, but yeah, it was honestly, like...
Um, it was honestly, like, such a great experience.
Oh, I actually got screenshots, too.
Let me...
I can show you guys some of the screenshots, um...
Of the concert.
Also, my...
I think my food's outside my door.
Um...
I'm so hungry.
I think you guys have no idea how hungry I am.
How hungry...
I'll show you guys.
Oh, I'll show you guys.
Oh, they're, like, HD, too.
Ooh.
Oh, I'll show you this.
Oh, my gosh.
I have screenshots of it.
Uh, that they sent me.
Oh, no.
Okay, wait.
Sorry, I, like...
I, like, resized it outside.
Oh, look.
Oh, my God.
Look.
It's a doll kitty.
Oh, my God.
That's me.
And then there's...
Let's see.
Which other one can I show you guys?
Uh...
And then there's...
It's, like, Nya?
So cute!
Ah!
And...
Which other ones can I show you guys?
I can show you guys...
I think this, too.
Ooh.
Look.
It's so aesthetic.
Ooh.
Look at that.
Whoa.
Look how aesthetically pleasing this looks.
But you can see, like, some of the things I want to fix.
So, um, this was something we couldn't fix because, um...
we would have...
It would take, like, a couple of days to do.
Um, but we didn't have time for that.
So, like, we've noticed this, like, literally on the day of the concert.
Uh, which was the shadow texture.
So, this is, like, one of the things I want to fix on the polished version.
Which was the, um...
The texture of the shadows.
So, you can see that it's not transparent.
Um, and that was, like, a little thing that we forgot to do because it was, you know, it was just, like, little things that I want to fix.
So, you know, for the YouTube, um, upload, I do want to, like...
We can do it.
We just forgot.
Like, the production team just forgot to, like, fix that part.
And obviously, like, with all the things that were going on, um, with...
To make this done in a month, like, obviously, that slipped through.
And I think that's okay.
I think it's okay during, like, the concert version of it.
Like, you know, the live concert version of it.
Um, but, like, you can see, like, here that it's not transparent, uh, uh, on the shadow, the shadow texture.
So that's, like, one of...
That's why...
Why...
Why one of the reason why I wanted to, like, uh, polish it more, too, so that you guys get, like, you know, the best quality version of this.
Um, uh, but yeah, anyway, let me grab my food real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm so hungry.
I'm sorry.
I keep saying I'm hungry, but I'm really hungry.
I'm not time.
I'm on something real quick before we...
before we go back, because...
Come on, this.
I ordered, like, mentaiko udon.
They didn't give me chopsticks!
Are you fucking kidding?
Okay, guys, let me decide.
I need to grab chopsticks.
I'll be right back.
This always happens when I, like, order late night.
They, like, always...
They never give me, like, utensils, even when I request utensils late at night.
I don't know.
It's always, like, late night stuff when that happens.
Um...
I have to wash the chopsticks, too, because...
Oh, my God.
It looks so good.
Ah...
My birthday mukbang.
Okay.
Dad might start barking, though, because he's been, like, pretty bratty lately.
Um...
He's been really, really bratty.
Also...
Okay, I know I'm...
I should talk about this while I'm eating.
I'm...
Oh, my God.
I have no idea how fucking overfed.
He was so overfed when I brought him back from the dog sitter because, like, ever since then, he does little boy poops.
I was like...
I was like, how did that came out of your bot three, four, five times, by the way?
Like, five fucking times in, like, one sitting.
I was like, how the fuck did that happen?
And now, like, since then, it's just little boy poops.
I don't understand.
Like...
The fucking incident.
Oh, my gosh.
Let me...
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom this real quick.
I just want one...
At least one bite before I start talking.
I muted myself a little bit because I don't want to hear me slurping.
There's more than one bite.
I can't stop.
All right, I couldn't...
I couldn't stop.
I know I said one bite and then I was like, oh, my God.
It's so good.
I was like, oh, my God.
Maybe it's not gonna be one bite.
It's so good.
Um...
But yeah, um...
I really appreciate...
I really...
Um...
I want to say enjoy the experience.
It was so fucking stressful.
I...
My staff team was like, you're fucking crazy.
Because...
If you guys...
Okay, um...
Because for the birthday stream, I also have a very...
Something very special plan for the birthday stream.
So my staff was like, you're fucking crazy doing both of these at the same time.
Because for those who didn't know, my staff team did not help me for the concert.
Like, that was my choice.
And that was a fucking stupid choice.
It was literally me and the production team in a Discord server together.
My staff team wasn't in there because I was like, no, no, I want to handle all of this myself.
Because I was like, I want...
Like, I wanted to do...
Because, like, it was my vision.
So I was like, no, I want to do this all myself because it was my vision.
And, like, I want to make sure, like, my vision is... the vision I have can be done.
So I was like, I want to, like, be fully in charge of this myself.
So I did delegate this one.
I mean, to be fair, my staff was at... I did have my staff at Anime Expo.
So, like, one of my staff members was there to help coordinate everything as well.
And, like, she was... we had one of our staff members there to help with a lot of stuff.
For those... oh, yeah, by the way, if you're at Anime Expo, we are auctioning off the...
We are auctioning off the concert stand, which is apparently fucking huge.
I saw... I saw... I don't know.
If you live in L.A., you might be able to win the birthday concert stand.
So, it's up to... it was very expensive, by the way.
That's actually, like, a last-minute idea.
By my staff member that was on-site.
Um, because, like I said...
Also, I can't believe there was a middle screen in the end.
That was not on the map.
And it was never told to us.
Like...
I was like...
So, there was a middle screen.
But it was, like...
In front of some of the rows.
So, people who were at the back...
Um, can see the middle screen.
Um...
But, like, if you were in the front row, you don't get the middle screen.
Because it was, like, at the back.
So, like, you know, it was a couple of rows after.
So...
But there was a fucking middle screen.
I was like...
I was like, wait a minute.
What the fuck is that?
I was like...
That's the screen right here.
And he was like...
I was like...
I know.
It wasn't on the map.
Like, I...
I don't know why.
Why the fuck wasn't that on the map?
I...
But anyway...
Um...
It was her idea to get the...
The stands and stuff.
Because we were like...
Like, what do we do for the center?
Because, like...
Look, I have no...
Nothing against unions.
Or, like, the fire marshals.
Because apparently, Anime Expo had, like...
A fire...
Like...
Not a fire incident.
But there was, like...
Smoke, apparently.
At Anime Expo.
Um...
Where, like...
One of the halls was, like, filled with smoke or some shit.
Because they...
They're, like, one of the fans, like...
Broke or some shit.
So, like, you know...
They got for the fire marshals there.
Um...
Yeah, so...
They're, like, you can't have a middle screen.
Um...
Because of it.
And I was, like, why the fuck didn't they tell us about the middle screen?
That's clearly there!
It wasn't on the map, though.
Um...
Yeah, I saw that tweet.
I was, like, oh shit.
I hope I can still do my content.
But, yeah.
It was...
It was such a challenge.
Because this was the first time that...
Well, not the first time.
But it was my own concert, you know?
Like, um...
It was my own thing.
Because I feel like I wouldn't really get invited to these types of actual...
Like, you know, like, big-ass concert-type deals.
Where, like...
Um...
At the concert venue.
Because, like, as you guys know, I'm not really, like, the singer...
The singer VTuber.
Like, I...
I, you know, I'm more so, like...
I play video games.
So, that's what I'm known for.
I play video games and...
And sometimes I play them pretty well.
Um...
And that's what I'm known for.
So, it was, like, a challenge to myself.
And...
I guess, like, to...
Like, just a challenge to myself as well.
And to be see...
To see if I could do it.
If I could...
If I'm able to do something like this.
Do, like, uh...
Um...
Like, my own concert type deal.
So...
I do want...
I mean, I...
I would love to do something like the Phantom Thief concert again.
Like, at an actual venue for concerts and stuff.
Because, obviously, like, you know, it was at Anime Expo.
Um...
So, like, obviously, the venue wasn't meant to be for, like, concerts.
It was for panels and stuff.
Um...
But I would love to do it again.
In an actual concert venue.
And everything.
But I'm glad people enjoy it.
But apparently, from what I was told from my staff members, was that it was, like, fully packed.
Um...
And, like, if you guys see empty chairs, it's because some of them, like, moved to the front.
So, like, some...
Like, there were, like, um...
If there was, like, empty chairs, it's because some of them moved to the front to do, like, you know, chair on in the front.
Like, with Watage and stuff like that.
Um...
But my staff members said that it was, like, a packed full room.
Which I think was...
I don't know.
I think it was, like, a thousand...
Six hundred...
Plus, I believe.
So, um, uh, so I think, I think it was a thousand six, I don't know, someone can fact check me, but, um, and, uh, my staff said, like, they had to turn some people away because, you know, fire marshal a lot.
I'm just happy.
I was like, I hope people count.
I mean, it's free.
I was like, that was all I wanted.
I was like, I hope people come.
Please, it's free.
Like, it's a, oh, it was 1800.
Holy shit.
Okay, that's a lot more.
It was, it was 1800 people there.
So, I was like, oh my god, please, it's free.
Please come.
Um, please, I spent so much money.
Oh yeah, I remember, like, Limu was asking me, I was like, so, like, um, do you get, like, money out of this, doing this?
I was like, yeah, we, no.
They were like, so, like, what's the benefit of doing the, this concert, like, doing this concert?
Do you get, like, do you get paid?
Or, like, did Anime Expo pay you?
Or, like, um, um, or, or, or, like, like, what's the benefit?
I was like, what do you mean?
It came out of my own wallet.
What do you mean I get paid?
I'm paying this.
I got, okay.
That's why I was like, usually, like, what's the benefit?
I was like, yeah, it's more so, like, for exposure, you know?
Um, it's like, investing in myself.
Um, yeah.
Yeah, so how is this?
Investing in myself, you know?
Like, it's like, you know, it's like, advertisement.
Just like, you know, maybe, like, some people who were normally never watched me before gets to, like, you know, enjoy, enjoy this concert.
So, like, yeah, I did take the concert a little bit more seriously.
I mean, I fucking sang in Japanese.
How much serious can you get?
I should post that much, this time around.
Five figures to say, buy my merch is...
Guys, I need to get my money back.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
After what I've spent...
Oh yeah, by the way, I basically shilled my merch three separate times.
Like, once in the intro, again at the end of the concert, and then like, the after credits scene.
I shilled my merch again.
I was like, please, please, please buy my merch, please.
I said so.
I really need people to buy my merch.
Please...
You gotta do what you gotta do.
No, you'll understand tomorrow.
I'll reveal it all.
You'll understand tomorrow.
I was like, guys, please.
It's like, literally right there.
Like, you can get it right now, please.
Rodrigo, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Um, investing your own community always pays off.
Thank you for everything you do for us, Toki.
We love you so much.
Thank you for the super chat, Rodrigo.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm really happy.
Like, like I said, I know some guys are like, ah, FOMO!
Ah!
Um, but don't worry.
It will be uploaded here.
And I will add more stuff to the concert itself.
Um, so that, um, so that, uh, you got like for those who waited, you know, get a bonus, something bonus for it, for it as well.
Um, uh, but yeah.
Um, yeah, like, I was told by my staff members that there was, uh, there was like a lot, you know how people are like subtle marketing, like, um, what was it called?
Where like, you do like subtle marketing where it's like, just, they just like, do it like, where it's just like on your mind, but it's not like over and stuff like that.
I don't, I just like be like, no, you have to buy.
It's very, it's explicit marketing.
There's no subliminal messaging here.
It's all, it's very explicit on what I want you to do.
What was I talking about earlier?
I already forgot.
Um, oh shit, two more minutes.
Um, oh yeah, my staff said there were like lines for my booth, so thank you guys for those who are at Anime Expo.
I really appreciate you guys.
Um, I really appreciate you guys doing that.
Thank you.
I'm glad that my aggressive, aggressive marketing is working.
Oh my god!
We're almost there.
Two more minutes, guys.
Oh, less than two more minutes.
Next thing, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
So glad I got to celebrate it with you at the concert.
Here's the fee for my ticket.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you guys so much.
Oh my god.
Um, I'm so nervous for my own birthday.
It'll be the first time.
Like, I guess like technically like celebrating it on my own versus like in IRL, but like I'm glad to have you guys there for my birthday.
I really do appreciate it.
Um, I was like, you know, um, I very, I really appreciate you guys being there with me and um, spending your time with me for my special day.
Oh my gosh, 20 seconds left.
One more bite.
Okay, you guys ready for a countdown?
You guys ready?
Oh my god, what the fu- Okay, it's on seven, six, five, oh wait, five, five, five, four, three, two, one!
Whoa, yes!
Dada!
Yes!
We're gonna have another outfit!
It's tomorrow.
It's gonna be tomorrow.
Yes, back to back.
This one is fully designed by my mama.
So the swimsuit was a charity auction winner design.
And it was designed by the charity auction winner and her friends.
But the next one is designed fully.
It's my outfit.
That was also sort of from the charity.
Actually, no.
I think it was chat chooses.
I think it was chat chooses the outfit topic.
And then I mixed it together with school.
So tomorrow we're doing another outfit reveal on my birthday.
And it is school theme.
Welcome back to school.
You think summer...
Summer vacation already ended.
It's like, yay, beach episode!
Now it's time to go back to school.
Summer vacation is over already.
We're going back to school now.
Um...
Marty, thank you for the five gifts and shoes.
Thank you.
Um...
Thank you for the...
Super chat.
Thank you.
Birthday money.
So technically getting today...
I realized it was technically today because it's...
Um...
July 4th.
So...
Yes.
For my birthday, we're gonna have a little...
Another outfit reveal.
And we're gonna have...
Also another announcement!
At the end of the stream.
Um...
The birthday stream itself won't be like super duper long.
Don't worry.
I'm not gonna do like a fucking...
Six plus hour stream.
On my birthday.
Um...
So...
But...
Um...
Most likely the announcement will...
It will be at...
Uh...
At the end.
For tomorrow's stream as well.
But...
The particular theme for tomorrow's stream...
Uh...
Today.
Sorry.
I keep forgetting like it's midnight.
Hahaha.
For today.
Um...
Is a school outfit reveal.
And the stream will be...
Obviously it will be at...
5pm PSD.
Um...
So be there.
Be square.
Whoa!
Hahaha.
Yes.
Double the announcements.
You guys are white knight now.
Okay.
So by the way.
I have a story for you guys.
About that.
Outfit trailer.
So this one wasn't done by my usual...
Editor.
Um...
Because I was stupid.
And I forgot to tell my editor.
What...
What date the outfit reveal was.
Because...
She was on vacation.
Around...
Um...
The end of June.
Like around end of June.
So like...
She was the one that didn't mind.
She's my go-to person to do all my outfit teasers.
So...
All my outfit reveal teasers.
Um...
So she's done like, you know...
Even before times.
Uh...
She did all the...
You might...
Her style is very recognizable.
Um...
So...
For this one, she also did my summer one as well.
And...
So...
I forgot to...
For me to do my...
June and July outfit reveal.
And she was like...
Yeah.
I can do it.
But then I forgot to tell her July's date.
So she assumed it was...
End of July.
Or like...
Middle of July.
But I didn't tell her it was actually the beginning of July.
And I didn't realize that.
Um...
She was like...
Oh yeah, by the way, I'll be gone at the end of June.
So I was just like...
Oh...
I was like, yeah, that's fine.
And...
Um...
But I thought that...
You know, she was working on it before then.
So...
Um...
Literally, like...
I think it was like...
Two or...
Three days...
Before the...
Before the stream.
Yeah, three days before the stream.
I messaged her.
And be like...
Oh, hey, like...
How's the progress?
And I was like...
And then I like...
Looked back our message history.
And I was like...
Wait, I never told her.
I was like...
I was looking through a message.
Oh, fuck.
I never told her.
When it was.
I was like...
Java, thank you for the...
Aka, aka, aka, aka.
Thank you so much.
Happy birthday, Doki.
I don't really attend events on account of accounts.
But I'm glad it helped offset the cost even just a little.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much for the insane support.
Thank you again.
It means so much.
Even though you can't attend the events.
I hope that I still cheer you up by just streaming here as well.
And doing the things I can do online.
But thank you again, Java.
Thank you.
But yeah.
Anyway.
So I was like...
My bad.
I don't know if you've worked on it yet or not.
But like...
Do you think it can be done in time?
And then I didn't hear anything.
After half a...
Like a day later.
Almost a day later.
I didn't hear anything.
And that's why you saw me tweet out.
Looking for emergency editor.
Emergency commission.
Like...
Right?
I...
Like me to please.
Looking for emergency motion graphics editor.
That was basically it.
That was the emergency.
Um...
Billy, thank you for the...
Give the chips.
Thank you.
Uh...
So...
Yeah.
It was for the reveal trailer.
Um...
Then I was like...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe...
I...
Hannah...
I forgot...
To like tell her the dates.
So...
Huge shout-out...
To the editor...
For being able to do this within...
Within...
Like...
I don't know.
Um...
I think like within like two days.
So...
Huge shout-out.
Um...
The editor was....
Reyna Ilun!
They done like...
I think they done like music videos.
I'm pretty sure...
They were the ones that did like...
Music videos for Kiara...
Uh...
For her songs and stuff like that.
So...
Can you shout out to her?
She replied to my tweet, be like, I could do it.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So they did that reveal trailer, the teaser.
They did the reveal trailer in two days.
Thank God.
Shout out to her.
I fucked up.
I'm just glad they were able to do it.
But yes, that is the announcement.
I'll show it again for those who didn't see it.
I'll show you guys the reveal trailer right now.
So yeah, I'm super...
Oh yeah, let me show you guys the silhouette too.
Let me grab that real quick.
Let me make sure I don't...
What if I just accidentally leak my outfit right here?
I'm going to do something I could do.
I would have accidentally...
Honestly, I won't be surprised if that's something I couldn't accidentally do.
Okay.
Let me make sure I don't do that.
I'm just going to be like, what?
The reveal is actually here.
That's the secret announcement.
Alright, let me grab the silhouette real quick for us.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, this is definitely...
I double checked.
This is the silhouette.
Alright.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tips on being the nerd goon.
Doki shoves in the locker first.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let me...
Okay, I'm paranoid.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, so...
This is the...
This is the actual silhouette.
I will tell you guys right now.
There is actually another toggle where I wear a different hoodie.
So...
Slash...
Okay, I won't say hoodie.
Let me jack it.
So...
It's obviously because there's a hood there.
So like...
So there is a different...
There is a...
Also a toggle where it becomes a different jacket slash hoodie.
So I'll let you guys know that for now.
Um...
But yes, this is the silhouette for...
I know, like...
Back-to-back outfit reviews.
I think this is like...
This might be like the shortest, like...
You know, from like no outfits to suddenly we have two...
From waiting a year for the new outfit to suddenly waiting for like...
Two to three weeks for the second one.
I'm so bad.
Because I was like...
What do I do for my fucking birthday?
I was like...
Um...
So remember what I was telling you guys like...
Oh wait, you guys didn't know.
Okay.
Um...
For those who don't know...
Obviously like...
Celia.
She's incredibly talented.
And like obviously...
You know...
Everything...
My movement and everything...
For like...
Um...
Rigging for...
Skinsuits.
She's incredibly...
Uh...
We had a good run.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
No, this was done by...
This is also done by Celia.
But for those who don't know...
But she's like...
Obviously she's like...
Incredibly busy.
And everything, because, like, there's so many of us that... And, like, her work is, like, obviously, her work is insane.
Like, she... Like, I don't know if you guys saw all her tweets about, like... About, like, how many, like... Like, how much is done for her rigs and everything.
For the skin suits.
And, um... And so, like... Because of that, because she has so many, like, you know, people... She has so many kids.
Uh... We all... Obviously, we all want her to do our rigging.
Um... So, now there is, uh... Uh... There is a limit to, like... So, like, everybody has, like, an equal chance.
Uh... To, like, you know, have something new from her.
Um... So, we're all limited to, like... One outfit.
Or, like, one new... One new outfit per year.
Um... I'm greedy.
I got two.
I... I... I... I... I got there before the limit was set.
I... I... I... I basically... I grabbed... I got there before she set the limit.
I was, like... I was, like... I'm greedy.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Um,
I might, because I do have a lot of outfit ideas that I really want to do now.
So I might, um, maybe like one or two outfits.
If I do have another outfit this year, it will be, the rigging will be done by someone else.
Because I'm, I'm fucking greedy.
But, but I already, I already booked a slot with Celia for like, for next year's, um, for next year.
Like, uh, uh, uh, outfit.
So, like, I already booked a slot for like, January, 2026.
Because I was, I'm, I want more!
The game doesn't stop.
I want more!
Feed me!
Dookie's stocks go up.
Yes, but I do have some inciting, exciting stuff.
To show you guys, tomorrow, today.
Sorry, today.
I keep forgetting that it's July 4th.
Happy birthday to me!
Yippee!
Uh, ha ha ha ha ha.
Feed me to see more.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Um, um, but I am, uh, uh, So, I want to know what.
Happy birthday, Dookie!
I'm disappointed in you.
You didn't do well in your map test.
Be my, oh my god.
If I get B minus on map, that's a win on my book.
So, I'm punishing you with a happy face.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know about you.
That's a win.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
That's a pass.
I take this.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Um, yeah, I'm looking forward to, I'm really excited for today.
I have so many special things planned.
But yeah, that's why I have the, the back-to-back outfit reveals.
Because I was like, what do I do for my, he's like, what's really difficult?
Is that, this was before the concert, by the way.
Anyway, this was before I got the, the, um, the, the concert deal with Anime Expo.
Um, or the concert deal at Anime Expo.
So, I was like, what do, what the fuck do I do for my birthday?
Sorry.
Um, I had, I'm eating my bentaco udon.
So, um.
Some of the, the fish eggs got stuck in the back of my throat.
So, it's like, irritating it.
Let me hydrate.
Real quick.
Ah!
Guys, there's no way I can choke on fucking fish eggs.
They're so tiny.
It's just irritating on my throat right now.
Hmm.
I was like, if I choke on figs, fish eggs, we have bigger problems.
Um.
Wait, what was I talking about?
Fuck!
Right.
My mind is all over the place.
Cough, cough, cough, cough.
That is just irritating my throat.
Um.
Guys, what was I talking about?
Cough, cough, cough.
I like how I'm choking, and I'm still eating.
Oh yeah, birthday!
Um...
So, um...
Oh my... God, it's still stuck.
Sorry, I have to like blow my nose too.
But anyway, so...
The outfit was planned before the concert was...
You know, before we had the concert idea.
So I was like, you know, I was like, what the fuck do I do for my birthday?
So the hardest part about my birthday stuff, or like any event stuff...
Is that...
I keep one-upping myself.
Like...
I need to stop doing all these creative big events every time on these...
Goddamn birthdays, anniversaries, and stuff like that.
Because I keep...
I keep making some crazy shit for all that.
Because it was so hard.
I was like, the fuck do I do on my birthday?
Like...
And I was like, you know what?
I haven't...
I haven't done a...
I haven't done an outfit reveal yet for my birthday.
So we'll just do that.
I know it's a lot simpler than my...
My birthdays in the past.
I've done some crazy shit for like birthdays and anniversaries.
But like...
So...
I know like...
It's not really an escalation on like...
Stuff I've done in the...
I've done a concert in a concert.
I did...
That's the escalation...
I did too...
But this is like actual like concert concert.
Like...
That was the bonus escalation.
Uh...
The power creep.
So...
So yes...
That's why we're having another outfit reveal.
Um...
For my birthday.
I know like...
We just had summer vacation.
We just had our beach episode.
But it's like...
It's like we're going by...
Anime time frame.
Like we have one beach episode.
And now...
And then it's back to school.
So...
That's why...
Now one...
One beach episode.
And now it's back to the school time.
That filler arc is over.
Uh...
I've never had it back.
Um...
But yeah, I do have like...
More stuff I want to tell you guys.
About...
The concert.
And like...
My birthdays.
And all like...
The stuff that's going into my birthday.
And everything.
But I feel like...
I want to save some of the...
Info...
For...
Tomorrow.
Oh no, sorry.
Today.
I want to save tomorrow!
I want to...
I...
I'm gonna save that...
Uh...
For...
Later today.
Where I'll go more...
Actually...
You guys might be...
Oh, was that not in depth?
No.
I'm gonna show you guys like...
Videos.
And screenshots.
Of like...
Um...
Scrapped things.
Like deleted scenes.
Like...
Deleted choreos.
And deleted props.
Stuff like that.
So...
Um...
Later today.
At 5pm PSD.
I'll show you guys more like...
Behind the scenes.
Of everything.
So...
Look forward to that!
Hey guys!
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm tired.
I'm eepy.
This was...
It was a very...
Very, very long day...
For me today.
Um...
Like...
It started...
I literally woke up at...
Three in the morning.
Because I had to be awake...
To be...
Go back to back...
With...
The...
Production team.
Um...
For the...
Uh...
3D concert.
So like...
I've been up since like...
Three in the morning.
And then I've only had like...
Miniature naps.
Here and there.
So I had like...
Three hours sleep.
And then I've had like...
Miniature naps...
Throughout the day.
So I...
Like...
We're cutting it so close by the way.
Everything was like...
Cut so fucking close.
I...
Oh my god.
I did so much traveling for this...
God damn...
Concert.
I mean...
Like...
When I tell you guys the price of the concert itself.
It does not include like...
The traveling fee.
The mixing fee.
For everything.
Um...
Like...
It did not...
It...
Like...
Oh my god.
I...
The...
Let's dance lessons too.
Oh...
My god.
It was so much money.
It was...
Also...
Um...
I tweeted about it.
But...
I know some people were like...
Oh yeah.
Some people were like...
What was the last song?
Um...
In the set list.
That was actually...
A preview.
Well...
I mean...
It's...
Technically finished.
But like...
This was like...
Recorded...
It's super fast.
Versus like...
Natural stereo recording.
But...
It was basically a concert version...
Of...
My original song.
Um...
So...
For those who didn't...
Were watching the recordings of it...
Um...
Like the...
The convention recordings...
Um...
Of the concert itself.
That was...
The last song was actually...
A preview...
Of my original song.
So that's why...
People were like...
What the fuck was...
Is she singing?
So...
So yeah.
Hey guys.
Um...
Well I don't know when...
The original song will actually be...
Out Out.
Because I haven't had the...
Music video...
Like...
Figured out yet.
Um...
I haven't contacted anybody...
For...
The music video.
So...
The MV is the one that takes the longest.
I...
I feel like.
MV is always the longest...
That's...
That...
That will take.
So...
Um...
So now...
It's more so like...
We're just waiting on...
Me figuring out the music video situation.
Um...
But yes.
I don't know when...
The original song...
Regarding the official release for it...
Will be done.
But...
Yeah.
So...
Like...
At least you get something out of it.
At least you get to hear it.
And...
As always everybody...
I'm gonna call it here.
Because...
I can be rested for it...
Later today.
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Oh my god.
Wait let me...
I need to stay hydrated.
Oh my god.
That mentaco is like...
Fucking me up.
But...
Thank you again...
For...
Coming to my countdown stream.
I hope you guys had a great time.
Hang out with me today.
I know like...
You know...
I wish I could stream longer.
But the longest stream will be for my actual birthday stream.
This is just a countdown.
Anyway guys...
Uh...
I'll show the...
I showed the...
Announcement trailer.
Revealed...
The teased...
Outfit debut trailer again.
Um...
To end the stream.
But as always everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Because...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Bye!